ترخص قطرات العرق هذه على جبين الحاج احمد
صالح صوره من مقاس الفقر والفقر المدفع
الذي يكسره انيابه عن الاف الاسري في
السودان البلد الذي اصبح منها كان
بالمعانه في هذا البيت يجلس الحاج صالح
وكانه يلملم جراحه بعد ما ادخله مرض
السكري الذي ينخروا جسده بسبب عدم مقدرته
في الانتظام على شراء الادويه لغلاء
اسعارها وعدم توفرها في معظم الصيدليات
فلا مال او دواء ولا وصفه طبيه ولا حتى
طبيب
لذلك اذا تحرر ولا ما تحرر ماذا
ب 50 الله اذا تحرر يبقى الدواء يعني
القرص الواحد
قرر مختصون خلال ورشه عمل انت حرير اسعار
الدواء المستورد
ومعها حظر تجمع الصياد الى المهنيين من
خطوره مثل هذه الخطوه قائلين انها ستؤدي
الى مضاعفه اسعار الدواء الحاجه دي طبعا
يعني انعكاسه على المواطن السوداني في ظل
الوضع الاقتصادي بيعيشوا كل الشعب
السوداني هو يعني الجريمه بالصبغه الاصرار
والترص يعني كل ذلك ياتي تزامنا مع تدهور
الخدمات الصحيه في البلاد وانعدام اكثر من
1000 صنف من اصل 1700 دوائيا اختفت من
الاسواق واتهامات للسلطات بالتواصل
المسؤولياتها تجاه توفير الادويه المنقذه
للحياه
توفر العلاج مجانا لانه في كل المنظمات
الحقوقيه في العالم المتحده والجهاد
المعنيه بالعلاج وبالمرضه وبكده
يعني اقروا و وضعت يعني
توجيهات وقوانين واضحه وصارمه انه العلاج
حق في 2019 بدات تسعير الدواء لهذا المرض
المزمن مقابل 18 جنيها سودانيا واليوم وصل
سعره الى 265 جنيها وستوقعات بوصول تسعيره
الادويه لما يزيد عن 500 جنيه ما يعني
مزيدا من المعاناه للمرضى محمد فروانه
العربيه